it's good to see you I got a lot you
sugarless yes to babies yes exhausting
and amazing and the light of my life I
love getting up every morning and
spending that quality time with them and
you know we got the masked singer show
on fox is premiering on Wednesday no I
love love love that show
it's so much fun thank you know what I
love about it every age group loves that
show yeah yeah there's a little
something for every but my 9 year old
grandfather and my 9 year old son both
enjoy the show
see that's the way I feel about it too I
watch it with my granddaughters and they
love it and I love it yeah it's nice to
bring different generations and and and
especially with everything that's going
on in this country to just drop it for
an hour and enjoy great singing and
great performances and the guessing game
is abuzz and now it's gonna be great for
you to do this show and be home for a
while
with the fans yes yeah I'm actually
going on tour in the middle of October
for the first time in many years so it's
gonna be it's gonna be difficult to be
away from them but so I'm soaking up all
the quality time right now
[Music]